USA Today reporting Americans are
borrowing more than ever for new and
used vehicles in 30 and 60 day
delinquency rates rose in the second
quarter the total balance of all
outstanding auto loans has reached over
a trillion dollars between April 1st and
June 30th the second consecutive quarter
that it surpassed the trillion dollar
mark more consumers are also turning to
leases fleeces which account for 31% of
all new car and truck transactions in
the second quarter up from 26 percent
both 30 and 60-day delinquencies rose
but the combined subprime and deep
subprime share of new and used auto
loans and leases dropped the average new
car loan was 29 thousand eight hundred
eighty dollars the average monthly
payment is 499 dollars up from 483 a lot
of these loans as long as 7 years I
gotta tell you that's just straight-up
stupid the largest thing you and I buy
that goes down in value is a car now I
like cars I got some nice cars now when
I was broke I didn't have any nice cars
I drove crap with wheels on it I mean
that's what I drove it was awful because
I figured out that rich people the way
they get rich is they drive used cars
with only payments four hundred and
ninety-nine dollars it's kinda like five
hundred dollars where I came from five
hundred dollars a month if you were to
invest that through your working
lifetime instead of keeping an average
car payment the average person would
have over six million dollars extra at
retirement
that's what your car is costing you
straight-up stupid that's just
straight-up stupid there's nothing else
you can call that I hope you like the
car it's a six million dollar stupid
decision when I was a little kid they
had this awful show on was the guy's
name Lee Majors the Six Million Dollar
Man didn't need anything anything did
anything he he would jump and he could
jump over houses and stuff because they
had put Bionic legs on him because he
had a wreck or something I don't
remember but it was anything anything
that's the net noise he made when he
jumped or whatever they'd have this
music behind him you could be the Six
Million Dollar Man if you didn't have a
car payment
Dean anything Indian what could you do
with six million dollars a lot how many
people could you help if you had six
million dollars a lot just the interest
is a half a million dollars a year the
income off of six million dollars
invested you could live on five hundred
thousand dollars a year for the rest of
your life didn't anything
are you kidding this is what your stupid
car is costing you and people are so
freakin desperate they go fleece a car a
third of you or that stupid which is
like stupid on steroids okay fleecing a
car is the most expensive way to operate
a vehicle according to Smart Money
Magazine consumer reports of my
calculator it's horrible
see there's this thing called
truth-in-lending the Federal Trade
Commission requires they give you this
little sheet of paper when you borrow
money and you're stupid on a car little
sheet of paper shows you what the
interest rate is what your payment is
and what your total payback is and it's
supposed to scare you to death because
you're stupid it doesn't work everybody
just initials it because they got car
fever and they woke out and they smell
that toxic leather smell or that toxic
plastic smell and they drive away with
this high thinking they just did
something smart
they didn't guess what you don't get a
truth-in-lending sheet showing you what
your effective APR is when you lease a
car you know why cuz you can borrow
money technically speaking the car
dealers love this
because they don't have to disclose what
your interest rate is so you don't know
how stupid you are you just know you're
stupid but you don't know where on the
stupid scale you are so let me help you
with this you can actually take a
financial calculator on car fleece and
put in what the effective interest rate
the effective interest rate by backing
into it and it's a little financial
formula it goes something like this
the value of the car at the time you buy
it versus the value of the car at the
time you give it back to them which is
stated in your closed in fleece it's
called your residual value it's the turn
in number that the car is worth at the
time you turn it in or they think it's
going to be worth at the time you turn
it in
you put those two numbers in there and
then you put what you're paying and you
can back out and you will figure out
exactly what the effective interest rate
was now it's not technically an interest
rate it's called a cost of capital
da-dum there's some nice words cost of
capital kind of sounds like an interest
rate doesn't it if you used your
freaking brain so there you go all right
and so now we have cost of capital the
cost of capital on a typical fleece I've
done I don't know probably 100 of these
calculations recently about 14.1 that's
the interest rate on your stupid fleece
stupid stupid stupid stupid stupid
straight-up stupid and 31% are stupid on
steroids
14% really I'm sophisticated I least my
car you're not sophisticated you're
stupid I mean straight up man I mean
borrow money on cars dumb borrow money
14% of cars double dumb this is double
dutch nom right here I mean seriously
think think think think think think use
critical thought you impulse a twenty
nine thousand dollar purchase you are
stupid I know all of this why because I
have been stupid I know what stupid
looks like I've done so many stupid
things and I worked with people that
have done stupid things now you're not
stupid you're just doing stupid stuff
but if you do stupid stuff long enough
you could be called stupid stupid is as
stupid does I think the philosopher
Forrest Gump said right or that was his
mother I believe if I'm
but anyway gotta stop it
499 dollars for a car payment what were
you thinking oh you weren't that's what
it was that's what it was nuts it's
gonna mean you work your whole freakin
life and you get to the end of your life
broke I sure hope the government which
is well known for its ability to handle
money will take care of me stupid
gotta stop it a trillion dollars for the
car debt in America today and you're
wondering why we have a college loan
crisis people giving all your money to
car companies instead of fun in your
kids college fund stupid it's stupid
gosh I hope I wasn't unclear I struggle
with clarity when I'm speaking sometimes
I want to make sure you guys really know
how I feel about this
this is the Dave Ramsey show hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show you can
do this you know that really is a
message whether you've got two hundred
seventy thousand dollars in student loan
debt or 27 thousand well you've got a
fifty thousand dollar income or a five
hundred thousand dollar income
you